beh ragazzi e benvenuto subito dio il
rocket big quel gioco bello dove c'è il
padre degli uk che deve andare sulla
bici ma quello è un altra roba beh sono
lo stesso buona visione
contro zero e nami guarda io ci credo io
ci credo ma google possa perfetto
perfetto che mi sono trovato un
messaggio in dall'ex su instagram della
voglia di bonolis che diceva tipo volete
andare in tv io non ho mai risposto alla
tipo del 2017 e che il comparto sta roba
perché dopo rifiuti vediamo bene
mamma mia aspetta la piazza ma che gol
che gol come ti amo avanti un altro
senza che questo è ufficialmente il 3 a
l'ho tolta come chi sono un portiere
pazzesco grazie a tutti dove il pallone
d'oro è troppo forte sarà galassi
madonna come però non ci sono più terzo
è bello avrà è bello e giusto così
perché non possiamo farli tutti noi
certo queste righe removibile di gol e
ci arriva e lo tolgo l'ho tolto lo bam
pato fortissimo bella 10 sta credendo al
pandino a metano attenzione ok livello
ma che schiaccia questo
maledizione noti anche pronto e l'ho
tolta male per la meglio perché sono
rischiavo di farlo di fare gol
va bene va bene va bene però controllare
guardate con che l'ente statale c 6 c 6
sono bravo però ne vado è questa finisce
4 volte lo contate tutte mi è capitato
di giocare da mezzo addormentato e ho
dormito con 34 ore tutte e tre le volte
ho fatto dei punteggi pazzeschi te lo
giuro
toccherà a guidarmi ogni volta che darmi
poi non dormo niente così te lo giuro
inizio veramente io è veramente penso
che sia veramente utile sta cosa perché
si vede che penso meno non sono serio
secondo me veramente c'era guarda guarda
che gol mentre accusato in caso di
terminando a interpretare che sei stanco
sulle 7 30 ora di dormire sono già le 4
di notte mediche funziona guardato ha
funzionato per un mese contro del
mattino come sono difficili ma per
questo giocando con la vulcano cambiato
solo cambiato macchina e allora ciao è
presente quando devi premere l'analogico
per farla roteare ma non lo fai quindi
fondato il jumper mister lo faccio
sempre
ecco quello bella e sei da solo se la
tocchi vai vai perfetto ggt riafferma
non evere no dai non ci credo che sfiga
ti prego guarda questi greco queste
sfiga pieno guarda guarda la palla è
finita esattamente a lui e io anche in
anticipo perché lo sapevo che ti segnava
così non sollecita a toglierla tutto
sbagliato tutto giusto dipende dal team
però turbo torna in porta fortissimo una
cacca incredibile tranqui
mamma mia allora vi bravi bravi bravi
bruno credo ce l'avrebbe parata ma sono
andata a caccia e l'ho fatto frenare e
cécile avrebbe parlato perché vedo meno
che arrivato un po forse la buttava
dentro provato cavascura attenzione maya
va bene guardate la riva e tutto è
pronto
bravissimo te la tolgo io grazie grazie
che sto meritato grazie pollice in su
del video grazie grazie
ok ma è gol no attenzione e colle perché
è giustamente ha detto guarda non gliela
faccio toccare a noi la tv che ho
pensato non devo mandare la sanità
perché me la ruby va bene non si ci
credo giurate lo giuro che ci credo che
mi hai fatto benissimo fatti ha segnato
lui circa 23 anche questi su rendono
occhio che sono le 4 40 del mattino
brahms 2 dai questa possiamo vincere se
è vero sono fermi però dimmiquando dove
vincere questa partita c'è proprio il
risultato finale 5 1 ok alla questo il
primo gol ballo vero allora eccolo qua è
la prima è fatto
abbiamo problema vediamo eccolo qua il
primo dei loro e adesso sono sicuro
tutto va bene mancherà solo 4 dai va
bene quattro gol per noi ci sei
penso io ci sarò il primo è questo oddio
non ci credo
vedo che ora ne mancano tre guarda
guarda alla qui ovviamente non si fa
c'erano 52 quali non si fanno non va
bene
bello quello lo sai
il sistema ha capito più niente neanche
lui guarda allora quello arriva e tirana
cannonata anzi palla alta da ritoccare
per lui si ferma non è positivo perché
questo è il terzo signori anche se la
mia 3 a 1 raga pazzesca adesso aspettate
arrivano anche nel t2 tutto quello che
va letta se tra due già persa perché
nessuno può consegnare mai
no no non avevamo più segnare
no no no no no no ok vada vada vada vada
rischio perfetto ma va bene va bene va
beh sì sì sì sì ma se hai dato sulla
luna si ok perfetto la prende parola
gente senato è l'altra non ci credo
volevo anch'io ma poi 9 ok va bene va
bene va bene turbo turbo turbo io sto
tornando a segnare
eccomi buongiorno bravissimo io ci sto
credendo anch'io la stavo togliendo loro
tolto non ci credono non possono segnare
meno male a riva dal nulla non possono
segnare
no niente ragazzi il fatto è stato
disintegrato
mariano pezzi e abbiamo perso abbiamo
perso
peccato ecco non devi andare dritto di
vedere il dritto ragazzi come va dritto
lui comunque nessuno al mondo ha scritto
il versetto acqua addirittura il dito
dalla lunetta
sembra quasi un righello addirittura
rete è una linea dritta perfetta io
spero che vi apprezziate queste cose
alla tutto bene
madonna non ci fosse non può esserci
sempre qualcuno dovesse tirare ma fu
guardalà
bravo fa vj bravissimo come ti meriti
questo computer a 15 km
mamma mia no mai
[Applauso]
basta palla e sono contro un altro dito
nuova per non succede come il 35 cosa
integrato 5 goals devo fare no non
abbiamo fatto niente noi ma ti prego no
questa volta non imei chiocchio mila per
favore ce la facciamo finita facciamo e
si guarda allora sono pronto a meno che
non era facile ma prodi prima ciak a
riccio guy
[Musica]